Why do Elon Musk's words regularly go
viral and move markets when his speaking
technique appears to be so terrible?
He's not polished.
>> So so it's it's sort of quite quite fun
to do that.
>> His answers are full of filler words.
>> Um and uh you know um What does he know
that good speakers don't? I've
discovered four things he does
incredibly well that make him so
compelling. So let's break it down
starting with the first mystery, how
Elon gets away with rambling responses.
Why do you like the letter X as much as
you do?
Well,
>> [laughter]
>> So anyway, so it's so this long-winded
way of saying we're we're visiting this
idea that I had 25 years ago to create a
more efficient money database. Did you
catch it? Elon went rambling about X,
payments, information theory, and then
suddenly he realizes that he's been
rambling for too long and he snaps back
with six words. So anyway, so it's so
this long-winded way of saying And he's
back on track. This technique is called
a summary prompt. A summary prompt is a
technique that signals to you and your
audience that you're about to deliver
your main message. Bottom line is I
think But at the end of the day Well, I
think ultimately the the fundamental
value of the net effect The net effect
is So the most important toughest
remaining problem is it What matters is
that it is solved. What matters is that
it it is achieved. That's what really
matters. Making more than you take.
What studies show is that all speaking
starts in a pre-verbal state in your
subconscious. And when you're speaking,
your subconscious is just delivering the
auto-completion of your sentences. And
when you use something like a summary
prompt, you're hijacking that process
and you're directing it to give you
exactly what you need. And [music] it's
beautiful because you can use this to
get rid of all of the rambling so that
people don't remember that and just
remember you landing strong with a
summarizing point. But now that you know
how Elon summarizes his point so that
his conclusions go viral instead of his
rambles, you're ready to understand the
second piece of Elon's speaking formula.
The way to think of the uh Neuralink
device is kind of like a
a Fitbit or an Apple Watch, but but with
with tiny tiny wires. Very very tiny
wires. Tiny tiny wires so tiny it's hard
to even see them. The actual topic Elon
was talking about just now is literally
neuroscience, but suddenly it's not.
It's a Fitbit for your brain.
How does he do that? The way to think of
the uh Neuralink device is kind of like
a
a Fitbit or an Apple Watch. The way to
think of this is
That's another prompt.
But it's not summarizing. This time it's
introducing a new idea. It's providing
clarity. Look at Elon in action. So one
way to think of the this is to say I
mean, the way to think of it is that I
guess rough way to think about it is
Yeah, one way to look at technology is
to Imagine you're very confident that we
were going to be visited by
super intelligent aliens. The real trick
of it is Here's the thing to understand
about like
>> The way I view it is a tiny candle
in a vast darkness. In each of these
examples, Elon isn't just signaling
here's my main point. What he's doing is
he's translating his ideas by taking
something that the audience doesn't
understand and he's using analogies,
mental models, or other illustrations to
transforming into something that they
do. You will sense this as well as
you're speaking and when you sense that
you're not being understood, you can
just reach for a prompt just like Elon
does. [music] I want to be clear or to
be clear what I mean and watch your
brain just fill in a way to clarify your
thinking. So now we have two pieces of
Elon's formula.
But Elon is notorious for a third
speaking issue. If you followed Elon at
all, you know that he is no stranger to
bold predictions. Whether it's cars that
can [music] drive themselves with zero
human interaction, self-sustaining Mars
colonies by 2050, or being able to
travel between LA and SF in 30 minutes.
So, how is it that even when those
claims sometimes seem ridiculous, Elon
still inspires such belief in his
listeners? It's actually the way he sets
up his sentences to inspire conviction.
>> I like I'm confident that if then I'm
confident that you can do I I'm
confident that Like I'm confident by
2030. We're very confident that can't
emphasize that enough. I I like really
can't emphasize this enough. And it's
very important to emphasize that One
thing that we can be quite certain of
There's no question in my mind. Mark my
words.
AI is far more dangerous than nukes.
Far. [music] This is our third prompt
type.
We call it the conviction prompt.
Even if you weren't sure what you were
going to say when you began, which is
the whole point of these prompts, your
prompt forces your brain into a state of
absolute certainty. There's different
flavors here. I'm confident that I can't
emphasize enough. No question in my
mind. Mark my words. Most of us think
expressing conviction means being a
louder or more emphatic. But in many
cases, it's just a matter of prompting
yourself with the right words. So, if
you feel like your audience is skeptical
or that you're making a point that is
counterintuitive and goes against common
wisdom, you can prompt your brain using
any of these phrases.
And a statement of conviction will
automatically follow. Once Elon
eliminates rambling, confusion, and
doubt, we're left with one final
mystery. It's the root of Elon's good
speaking that traditional speaking
coaches almost completely ignore. Watch
this viral clip of what happened when
Elon gets asked a question. Do your
tweets hurt the company? I can't get
these ads because of some of the things
you tweet. When Elon responds here, he
has 12 full seconds of silence on
camera. That's an eternity. It's
multiple lifetimes in media time.
You know, I'm reminded of the scene in
The Princess Bride. He confronts the
person who killed his father and he
says, "Offer me money. Offer me power. I
don't care."
Most speakers would panic and most
speaking coaches would tell you to fill
the space. Say something, anything. Elon
is willing to do something that
terrifies most speakers.
He thinks out loud.
>> [music]
>> He lets himself sound uncertain. He
pauses. He fumbles.
And he doesn't [music]
care. So, when we train CEOs, we call
this spontaneous speaking.
It's the meta skill of trusting your
brain to deliver the right words even
when you don't know what they are yet.
So, here's Elon Musk's meta pattern.
Elon thinks deeply about topics that he
cares about. He does the deep work in
that area. And when he answers a
question, he isn't afraid to think out
loud. Prompts his brain for summaries,
for clarity or conviction. And thanks to
the thinking that he's done previously,
his subconscious brain naturally serves
him what he needs. And that creates
answers that people remember and that
people share. Every single viral Elon
clip follows this pattern. This is what
we've discovered working with thousands
of people who want to improve their
speaking. You don't need to know where
you're going when you start speaking.
You just need to trust that your brain
will get you there. Internalize your
ideas.
Speak before you overthink. Use prompts
to nudge your brain to deliver what you
need when you need it and have the
courage to be imperfect and unpolished
along the way.
If you'd like to learn a totally
different way of using prompts from
someone who's considered a traditionally
good speaker, watch this video next
breaking down President Obama's most
effective speaking moves.